hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we are in a
game 7 at the 2016 World Chess
Championship first six games we've had
quite a bit of draws six draws so far
both sides tied up with three points a
piece getting half point four draw
coming into Game seven we have karyakin
playing the white pieces he played white
in Game six also gonna be getting those
in Game seven then we will alternate if
it does come to a game twelve Magnus
Carlsen will have the white pieces in
the last final game but cardiac can
starts out with pawn to d4 so something
a little bit different so that's always
good to see we've seen a lot of the pawn
to e4 pawn e5 getting into the right
Lopes with similar variations all
throughout the tournament so a pawn to
d4 is a nice change in pace for the
tournament pawn to d5 pawn to c4 so
getting into the Queen's Gambit line
pawn to c6 so kind of that slob defense
could get into the semi Slav if he wants
to play east six could always get his
LightSquared Bishop alt involved into
the pawn chain very common here to f5
and then we see cardiac in play Knight
to c3 and then Knight here to f6 and
it's somewhat common to see Knight to f3
and then response would be Bishop to f5
and then push here with pawn to e6
I want slice where bishops outside of
the pawn chain then to kind of lock that
up but it changes things after Knight to
c3 gets a little tricky with Bishop down
here to beat or f5 cuz in after the pawn
takes pawn recaptures Queen here to b3
attack in the pond and at this pawn here
on b7 I went this knight on c6 attack
and that block is gonna go down in
material so cardiac can decides to play
a little bit slightly different
variation bringing his knight here to c3
attack in the center instead of bringing
the knight over here to kind of stop
that Bishop from getting involved too
soon to f5 so nice to f6 from Magnus
Carlsen is just continuing his
development pawn to e3 pawn here to a6
and then Bishop to d3 and then we see
taking on c4 so I don't see a ton of
lines for Magnus Carlsen playing a
Queen's game at accepted line but he
choose
is to do that right now and then Bishop
takes on c4 usually don't want to move
your minor pieces multiple times but in
this particular case it makes a lot of
sense you need to go ahead and recapture
magnus carlsen is aware of this and so
one of the reasons you decide to go
ahead and play that accepted line after
your opponent plays Bishop here to d3 so
after the bishop takes on c4 pawn to e6
and the knight to f3 Carlsen now plays
pawn to c5 trying to break up the center
of the board and then castle on the King
side much prefer castle on the King side
then something like pawn to c5 you see
the Queen's come off the board I think
you see they're gonna have to move his
knight back to the one which he doesn't
want to do or you could capture with
this King Bishop comes down here c5 pawn
to b3 knight c6 and black and even
castle can get pretty aggressive castle
on the Queen set if you want it doesn't
have to worry as much because the
Queen's off the board this would just be
pretty brutal for for a white to kind of
lose his advantage definitely don't want
to be seen there so we didn't instead we
see castle on the King side pawn down to
b5 forcing the bishop move Bishop back
here to e2 Bishop e7 attacking this
nights here on f3 part of the reason
that the bishop came back here to e2 he
wants to make sure his Queens that tie
down any pieces on the board pawn to a
c5 black could recapture if he wants to
with his bishop but he knows that move
is gonna be there for a while first
decides to play Knight here to c6 he
does have the option to bring his queen
down here but it's a little worse than
before cuz Queen takes on d1 ok well now
listen just cardiac and responds takes
on d1 he's controlling it's open file
with his rook that's gonna be completely
fine for white so Magnus Carlsen decides
not to do that at this point instead
Knight here to c6 and then night down
here to d2 and night to d2 is somewhat
odd he has lots of different options
here you know even if he were to take
with Queen takes on d8 it's definitely
interesting the the rook recaptures a
pawn here to a3 Bishop takes on c5 pawn
appear to be 4 it's not too bad yes
rook is controlling the center of the
board but he still has a pretty good
position on board right here but he
decides to play something really odd he
gets his knight which is controlling the
center of the board he brings it over
here to d2 which is blocking off his
queen and also blocking off his bishop
here on c1 now his goal is to bring his
knight here to e4 and then eventually
come to this outpost here on d6 but I
think that's pretty optimistic that that
plan is gonna go according to plan
and so we see magnus carlsen first take
with his bishop here on c5 kind of
negating any goodness that you get from
a night here on e4
in my opinion now Knight to e4 first we
do see an exchange now the knight comes
to e4 it's not really doing too much
it's threatening this bishop but the
bishop can just easily come back here to
e7 which it does and then pawn to b3
another option but probably not as good
now would be queen up here to d8 and
then the rook recapture I think there's
less material on board for white to
really dominate or do anything in the
center of the board so now you're just
kind of giving your opponent this D foul
so don't like that as much decides to
instead play pawn to b3
Knight down here a B 4 and then Bishop
to f3 so there was a discovered attack
after the knight moves away the bishop
is now attacking this knight on e4 so a
few different options as far as how he
wants to approach that he could have
even tried something real crazy I wasn't
really expecting it but he could tried
Knight - D - that would be blocking a
lot of his moves but we've we've seen
some crazy moves from cardiac and in my
opinion instead decides to just play the
Bishop to f3 protecting it but he is
using a lot of pieces playing defense
not really being proactive in my opinion
castle on the kingside format is Crossin
a bishop to a3 he had lots of options
here you could have played Bishop to a3
I could have played Bishop to b2
couldn't even try that night to d2 as we
talked about that's that's always an
option but decided to go and play bish
to a three and then Brooke over here to
a c8 and this is interesting for man is
crossing because he also has lots of
different options when the board's
completely wide open you have tons of
material on board you have lots of
different avenues you can go through
instead of rook to c8 you could have
played Bishop to d5 nice little outpost
move and there's a couple options we get
a scene the bishop take here on b4
Bishop takes on b4 pawn up here to a3
force in the Bishop a [ __ ] get back to
e7 pawn up here to be for work over here
c8 controlling this open file I think
that's gonna be completely fine for
Magnus Carlsen if we come back and say
okay after the bishop to d5 what up
what if Knight to f6 kind of an
interesting move check and then what
could happen for me okay
the bishop takes here on f6 the bishop
takes on b4 since the bishop on e7 is no
longer protecting that then the bishop
comes down here takes on a1 because
you've takes on f Aether's we see a lot
of exchanges on board after the Queen
recaptures Queen over here to a-1 and
all of a sudden black has a pretty good
position I don't think he's necessarily
gonna win I think it's pretty draal
--is-- both sides are even in material
he does have a very active queen in the
center of the board I don't think he can
capitalize but all in all I think these
are pretty good for manage Carlsen in
the game he decides to play rook over
here to c8 which is met by the knight to
f6 check now things go a little bit
differently now because the bishop is
not here on d5 doesn't have protection
from the Queen doesn't have protection
from this pawn on e6
so now after the bishop takes on f6 we
see the bishop take on b7 slightly
different Bishop a1 Bishop takes here on
b4 so a lot of exchanges Bishop just
comes back here to f6 and then a bishop
takes on f8c the Queen come down here
and then after this take on f8 then
Bishop takes on a6 so cardiac and is up
a pawn in material so that's good I
think Magnus Carlsen maybe miscalculated
a little bit as far as how this in stage
right here would be so cardiac in has
the advantage but it is going to be very
difficult to really take this
turn it into when they have opposite
colored bishops which can be very drawl
it's just because you can't really force
your opponent to do anything you can't
block off some of the squares because
your Bishop has no effect on your
opponent's Bishop because they're on
opposite colors and so you'll see a lot
of these varied relish I think if magnus
carlsen had the white pieces he may try
for a very very long game in this
position but cardiac contrite ache his
slight advantage and turn it into a win
specifically on the Queen sign since he
has two pawns to manage Carlson's one
but pawn here to be for getting it on
the opposite color of the bishop to the
bishop can attack its rook over here c1
pawn to g6 rook up here to see two rook
over here a8 attacking both at the
bishop and at the pond part of the
reason why the Brooke came here to see
two to protect that pawn here on a two
bishop back here to a d3 rook d8 Bishop
e2 King f8 getting both the kings of all
them to the board rook over here to a8
Bishop c4 centralizing nice little
outpost not gonna be able to move that
at all King here to e2 kinis 7 pawn up
here F for both sides just pushing
material cinema board we're now past the
30 move mark very important in these
tournaments as they can't draw before
that spot King here to f3 a rook c7 g4 g
5 king to e4 and then rook to c8 so both
sides not really trying to break through
and in this position they decided to go
ahead and trawl the game after 33 moves
now just a little while ago I do think
if if Magnus Carlsen had the white
pieces this game could have gone on for
another five hours I don't know that
anything would have changed I think it
still would have been a drawing game I
think Magnus Carlsen really likes to
play those long games where he knows
that he can really can't lose the game
if anything he just puts so much
pressure on his opponent that something
could happen they could make a mistake
but I think he even realized in this
position that his opponent actually has
the advantage he's not gonna be
overcoming that advantage and then
creating his own
so he said okay let's go ahead and draw
this especially he's playing the black
pieces so draw seven games in a row draw
Magnus Carson will be coming back
tomorrow nights or tomorrow we'll be
doing the video tomorrow nights with the
white pieces he'll be looking for the
first victory in the tournament but
thanks everyone for watching we're more
than halfway through the tournament but
hopefully you're enjoying the videos and
I'll see you all in the next one thanks
again